he's smoking they're smoking already
there's a cat smoking everyone is
smoking I don't speak Russian so I don't
know how much can we all to understand I
think we're gonna be scolded a lot I'm
hoping there'll be a lot of dark humor
like it took a lot more effort than some
of the cartoons I watched growing up I
don't know whether it's day or night
like it's about this guy being sad and
lonely and looking for friends faces
there's a there's a darkness there whoa
is he sad or is he happy like he's
getting served divorce papers all right
oh my God look at that little guy he
would be cute in the daytime and really
freaky at night
everyone is smoking by fires in
cigarettes backwards to help Russian
people smoke oh my god hardcore I don't
trust that wolf Jake the vault is the
bad guy so this is the healthy guys not
smoking he's riding a bike think he's
gonna eat the bunny this seems like very
Looney Tunes ask daddy I think it
probably is more inappropriate for
today's audience
he doesn't have legs but he has feet
like this you only look monk it's kind
of like a weird acid trip it's like a
children's book but like animated I
can't forgive an American cartoon that
really looks like this so the most
graceful fall
I bet Russian people loved it in my
consistence I loved it in 2016 you gotta
remind me of winning the zoo is it
Winnie the Pooh oh my god yeah
I'm just impressed with like the quality
of this it's like a video game I'm
worried about that those animals safety
girl has a very short attention span but
also she's a child she seems like a tear
someone needs to teach her how to
properly play with animals going into
the forest oh the bear has its own home
he's an artisanal bear cleverer than me
no sweetie she hasn't learned yet how to
like treat other living beings she's
gonna come across that bear and I think
he's gonna teach her some life lessons I
honestly wish our cartoons were like
this is so cool
I'm like really impressive just like how
the cartoons look like just the
animation I might Bend watch it like I
would Bend watches I think they're like
way cooler than American cartoons